Senator Bernie Sanders said Biden who
kicked off his re-election campaign last
week could win in a landslide in 2024
given a current political backdrop of a
major political party the Republican
party where many of their leadership
doesn't even believe in democracy
Sanders stressed that he thinks Biden is
the Clear Choice for voters and if
Democrats and the president get stronger
on working-class issues and take on the
greed of the insurance companies working
class he believes Biden is going to win
a landslide Sanders waved off concerns
about Biden's age and stressed that what
voters have to look at is what does the
candidate stand for which side are they
on Jed when you hear a story like this
do you agree with Bernie Sanders that
Biden could win in a landslide I do
I do think he could win I think people
need to be prepared for that um and I
did I said this last time in fact we had
a a debate in my house uh my parents are
you know different degrees of
conservative but they were like oh
there's no way there's no way Biden's
gonna win I said he's going to win what
mark my words he is going to win and he
did and I think people need to be
prepared because corporate media wants
Biden to win and by the way that
includes Fox News they want button to
win they they do better when they're
going against Biden that that is their
business model that's how it works
um corporate media wants Biden to win
Hollywood once Biden to win the
entertainment business at large wants
button to win the system wants Biden to
win
um Biden has a lot of very powerful
people in his corner I think when you
couple that with the fact that the
Republican base is so split right now
between DeSantis and Trump as we talked
about before I think there are
weaknesses big weaknesses in both of
those candidates and I think you have
obstacles like young female single
voters they're not voting Republican
it's not happening they're looking for
Big Daddy government to be what you know
they're missing male head of household
used to be I know I'll get he for that
but it's true and you have a growing
segment of the population that wants
something for nothing they want
something for nothing and you have a lot
of people in this country now that are
deeply compliant that prefer for the
government to tell them what to do for
than for them to figure out how to do it
themselves do you have freedom lovers
yes do you have increasing number of
people who aren't that way yes so do I
think Joe Biden could win a landslide
yes I think that's a sad reality that
people should start to wrap their heads
around and I do believe by the way the
bigger fight and the more worthwhile
fight is in local politics is in
community politics go set yourself up
somewhere city state that you feel
supports and protects the values that
you believe in and those are the votes
that matter more than these National
actions so yeah
I I would not be surprised so are you
are you saying you may run for something
can you imagine me running back
I actually can you you'd have my vote
Tom thoughts on this Tom's gonna be my
running mate you're going to do the
business
[Laughter]
this country in ways that you don't
understand
I would vote you guys got my voice and
water remember with the Limestone the um
so what I think is going on here is
Judge Wright you know if this is
misplayed by the GOP this could be a
Biden Landslide but that's not going to
be a Biden lad Side by decision it'll be
by default here's what I mean by that if
the Republicans don't put together a
compelling case and a compelling
candidate served up in the right way
then it's going to look confusing and if
it's a bloodbath in the primaries and
everything kind of goes Haywire then
there's nothing for the voter to really
latch on to then you'll have a Biden
Landslide by default meaning there's
nothing for there's nothing to move that
10 12 percent of the independent voter
in the middle which is what the election
all national elections now hinge on so I
think it could happen but they've got to
get their act together now and make a
compelling case on the candidates and
not over package candidates and let them
be themselves because I think there's a
candidate in there the voters are going
to love and they're going to see the
contrast and they're going to want a
difference and it's going to be Stark
but in fact gets fumbled then you'll get
a you'll get a Landslide by default not
because they love it but just by default
because the 10 12 percent of the
independent middle aren't going to move
but just it blows my mind though that
that independent 10 15 12 cannot just
look at what the hell's going on nothing
is going right I don't care how you see
it where you left the right how how like
do you think Jed that the uh the whole
abortion stance that that can sway the
election one way or the other well I
think again you have those like young
female it's a very important voting
block people always underestimate that
young single woman that's who hears
these the wokeness who hears the
platitudes Biden talks in these like
ridiculous platitudes like he's
promising you the Sun the moon and the
stars who who's receptive to that you
have to be an emotional voter to be
receptive to that you have to be willing
to be the exact opposite of what Tom was
describing Tom was asking before well do
you think that you know voters are going
to be more practical that they're going
to look at the economy and they're going
to be able to get past character no the
emotional voters looking at oh that was
a mean tweet I can't go for him I'd
rather vote for this guy over here who
told me that there's leprechauns and
rainbows you know I want that that makes
me feel good about myself it's about
feelings not about actually benefiting
from policies yeah what's Vinnie what's
this video what is this so this is this
is Trump listen I laughed so as a
comedian this is he's up there and he's
talking about how Joe Biden talks and
doesn't know where the hell he is I saw
the one when they split it where he
actually saw the video of mine in but
this is one of the funniest this is
Trump is back and he's in full force and
he's talking crap go ahead rob you got
to show this do you think at least one
time you'd get up and say I'm running
for president uh where where am I going
where the hell am I going
and
[Music]
dude
that's the it that's the exactly yeah
[Applause]
a pre-packaged video
that took supposedly seven takes to get
it right if right is what you want to
call it oh man
and then he says he's running because
Trump and Maga pose a threat to
democracy can you believe it do and and
like come up that that's why don't you
mean you can't teach that yeah exactly
he did that off the cuff he didn't plan
that he just in his Trump World said you
know what yes I'm gonna go for it are
you more likely you know into the people
watching at home right now are you more
likely to watch a debate if Trump is in
it or if Trump is out let's say you know
half the debates have Trump in and half
the debates have Trump I guarantee you
the viewership takes a nosedive just
because people find this so entertaining
it's like watching a television show
unfold and he's totally on rehearsed I
love you you can't teach it so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you
[Music]